beyond parody mccormick now says  we might still win because of mail-in  ballots which of course the whole line  from the republican party has been  mail-in ballots are bad  mail-in ballots are fraud and now  mccormick is saying don't worry we've  still got the mail-in ballots coming  now we're gonna  we're gonna win this campaign we're  gonna win this campaign  and uh and tomorrow  right now we have tens of thousands  of mail-in ballots that have not been  counted that are going to need to be  counted beginning tomorrow  and uh and so that unfortunately we're  not going to have resolution tonight  but we can see the path ahead we can see  victory ahead  don't worry guys the mail-in ballots my  party has uh attacked for the last uh  two years are what ultimately will save  us